selon vous pourquoi Bruce Willis fait
malheureusement parler de lui depuis
vendredi il y a s'il te plaît j'ai rien
dit s'il te plaît
c'est un peu comme l'Alzheimer hyper un
peu là il a de la dégénéres c'est pire
c'est il a été déclaré des moments par
la médecine exactement
oui enfin au départ il était atteint
d'aphasie c'est la première étape
c'est-à-dire qu'il y avait des
difficultés à parler c'est pour ça qu'il
avait arrêté sa carrière et là c'est la
nouvelle étape c'est-à-dire que c'est de
la démence c'est une sorte de maladie
d'Alzheimer en peut-être encore plus
grave et plus rare dont il est atteint
de façon à peu près et ce qui est très
grave c'est je sais pas si vous
embarquez sur Netflix il fallait
plateformes il y a un nombre de nanas
avec lui en ce moment bien sûr mais les
deux dernières années où les médecins
lui ont dit dans deux ans vous ne serez
quasiment plus
autonome enfin vous aurez plus votre
tête et du coup pendant deux ans il a
tout accepté des cachets à deux trois
millions pour protéger sa famille il a
fait des nanas horribles sont plutôt
touchants et c'est c'est oui c'est dur
ça me fait penser moi mon héros c'était
Columbo je connais par cœur 69 épisodes
je les ai vu 53 fois et pour vous dire
anecdote quand j'ai fait décorer mon
appartement j'ai dit à l'architecte vous
prenez le premier épisode de Columbo
premier épisode de la saison 1 et vous
me faites le même c'est un truc
d'enfance je regardais avec ta mère
la moquette partout mais pour vous dire
qu'à la fin Colombo il se baladait dans
les rues de Los Angeles parfois en
caleçon tout seul et et la police le
ramenait comme ça il se perdait Peter
Falk parce qu'il était il y a des scènes
où on le
voit mieux et mordre les policiers
c'était mort des policiers tu feras pas
ça toi
je vous enterrerai tous
donc voilà c'est très très triste et au
fur et à mesure que l'État progresse
nous espérons que les médias se
concentreront sur les lumières de cette
maladie qui nécessite beaucoup plus de
sensibilisation et de recherche c'est
triste ce qui est mignon seulement c'est
que c'est à son ancienne femme qui a
toute la famille est réunie ils sont
très proches autour de lui mais c'est
vrai qu'ils parlent plus apparemment il
est agressif il parle plus et il a
quelques moments les gens qui
connaissent ça tu as deux trois moments
deux trois minutes de s'apparente à la
maladie d'Alzheimer c'est c'est horrible
et moi j'ai eu un ennemi qui a eu la
maladie d'Alzheimer je vous promets que
c'est quand vous voyez ce que vous voyez
parfois j'ai vu la personne se lever un
moment et dire bonne nuit aller dans la
cuisine et dire où il lit et cette même
personne que j'ai vu une fois il est
sorti d'un immeuble et il est il s'est
pris la porte en verre et j'ai dit à
cette personne pourquoi tu n'as pas
ouvert la porte il me dit ben parce que
j'avais oublié qu'une porte ça s'ouvrait
c'est c'est des maladies qui sont très
très triste et j'espère vraiment que
enfin voilà